good
[Music]
or good health until y jaramillo
with his report of the day o yúnes september 14
the company in remember
shorts announced the first casino where
smoking will not be allowed that's right
people will not be able to light their
cigarette inside andrew park  and of
no mar which is located within as
far as they reopen on september 30
this would be the last property
owned by the embryo to reopen
following closures due to the pandemic this is
the last week of the
clark county stop soft on go program
hosted by  state leaders
for totally free kobe tests
you can get one inside the
hendrix party at taxi station and
sandwich star jam until friday the
sites are open from six in the morning to
two in the afternoon only days of the
week you do not need to make an appointment on
president donald trump showed
up for his campaign event
inside the exprimer and texting in
henderson last night thousands of people
attended  this despite the
restrictions by the young line fin the
next stop
will be arizona and now we move on to
the weather forecast we start the
week with a sunny and hot day with
temperatures hovering around 100 degrees for
the maximum we will maintain these
temperatures for the rest of the week  week
approaching fall have a nice
day I'm sali jaramillo and this was your
brief information about houston in spanish
[Music]